welcome you know I'm doing this webinar
I'm looking at myself the whole time in
my head is so big I don't know what you
see on your in but I want to get started
so tonight I want to cover your eating
plan I want to cover your diet and what
you should be eating a lot of you okay
so some of you can see me and let me
know if you can see me I can see myself
okay good you can't see me okay good so
tonight we're going to talk about your
diet
a lot of you have entered in your what
you eat on a daily basis and we need to
talk because I see some things we need
to change but I went through as many as
I could squeeze in for the next half
hour so we're just going to go through
right through it and kind of analyze it
and I recommend take some notes and I
would take some of the things that I
show you tonight and help your friends
and neighbors and family so that way you
can analyze their diets as well so let's
let's just open my screen sharing here
and go right to let's see if I can find
it here I think it's where is this thing
here all right where are you let's see
close this down sorry about to delay
there we go perfect no it's right here
okay good
so died analysis the way I look at
someone's food log is I pretty much draw
a piece of paper and I look at all the
things that create health and all the
things that will destroy health and I
just go right down the list and I look
at it from the viewpoint of creating
health versus destroying health there
are some foods that are neutral foods
for example oatmeal really
have any nutrition in it but it's not
bad for you so I mean it's like eating
cardboard it's not going to kill you but
it is really not a nutrition in oatmeal
unfortunately unless you have steel cut
and there's some more nutrition but a
lot of people have the instant oatmeal
thinking that they're getting some
nutrition they're really not okay so
there are also foods that you omit in
your diet that will destroy your health
as well we'll cover that as we go
through I'm going to be talking about
from your eating plan based on fat
burning are you burning fat how to burn
fat what are you missing from your diet
what's going to stop you from burning
fat we're going to look at different
hormonal aspects and then also your body
type of course I did not ask those
questions as far as to determine your
body type but I'll go it through some
things with your body type so you can
kind of understand what you should be
eating based on your body type
reducing craving some of you crave
certain things I'm going to show you
what to do to get rid of cravings
because it's impossible to do a program
while your crave and then I'm going to
talk about how to get all the nutrition
that you really need from your diet okay
so with that let's go right into the
body types now I want to flip back here
from one second
let me see here okay I just saw a button
I to click so you could actually see can
you see my powerpoint presentation can
you see the body types on this hopefully
because I want to make sure that I'm not
doing like half the seminars and I find
out that you can't even see it I think
you can see it says you are screen
sharing presenting everyone so it should
be fine
so let's if you look at the first body
type on the left that is the adrenal
body type and those types generally
speaking need more protein than other
types not excessive amounts but they
need a little more protein because their
body is breaking down
more protein because the hormones are
are called catabolic that means hormones
that have the ability to break things
down faster than they can build back up
so those people need to have a little
more protein with each meal okay they
also are losing potassium through the
urine and they need to consume a lot of
potassium from their foods how do we get
potassium from vegetables so they need
to consume the greens but they tend to
have a bit more bloating with certain
vegetables so they might not be able to
do broccoli so we don't want them to
bloat while they eat so any more protein
I mean they don't want to do a complete
keep like a protein diet like an Atkins
diet because they're not going to get
any vitamins or minerals from the
vegetables so we need to beef up the
greens okay they also believe it or not
you know everyone's pushing this
alkaline diet you know alkalis or die
alkaline water well with the adrenal
their blood is excessively alkaline so
we need to Sidda PHY them they do really
well with things like apple cider
vinegar with water and a little lemon
with water kombucha tea they do very
well with that and then because that's
an adrenal type and they go through a
lot of stress they definitely need the D
vitamins but make sure that if you're
that type don't ever consume synthetic
unless you're doing some type of detox
but not long-term you want to get a
natural B complex I'm going to recommend
nutritional yeast and that will take
away a lot of stress mental stress
physical stress and the more you use
your your brain and your mind and you're
pushing yourself for the day the more B
vitamins that you deplete is
specifically b1 and one of the
interesting things that will indicate B
one is if you have nightmares if you
have excessive vivid dreams then you
need more b1 all right
as we go through this I'm going to
answer questions someone says my your
slide show is frozen that's because it
should be frozen I didn't move it it is
just on one slide right now
is salt substitute a source potassium no
but they do have different types of
potassium salts that you can consume
I recommend get your potassium from
vegetables but you're going to need five
to seven to even nine to ten cups of
salad a day it's not hard to do that
especially if you have you cut it up and
have it you know not like make it easy
to digest you don't have to always have
lettuce you can use cabbage as your
salad as well or spinach it's totally
fun
alright so so to summarize this type
right here first type needs more protein
more potassium more of an acidic drink B
vitamins and they also need some fat why
because their blood sugars are usually
off and they need some type of um don't
go low-fat with that type so I'm not
opposed to having more fat even meaty
fat in your diet because they they'll do
well on that it's not going to turn into
fat so as we go through this I do want
to let you know that the way that you
were probably taught that you have to
reduce your sodium your fat grams drink
more water or cut your calories that is
soon to be outdated information it's
just that's not workable all right so
let me go to the next body type and the
next one is the ovary type you can see
the hips that is an excessive estrogen
body type so let me make sure that you
can see that hopefully you can see that
um let me just make sure where am I here
now it disappeared let me just try to
find it because I want you to see this
next body type should be right there let
me see if it's coming up all right
entire screen try it again oh now where
is it entire screen no hmm okay so I'm
going to continue to try to figure out
where this slide went let me just click
off some of these other slides real fast
so I can do this maybe it'll work right
now let's see if it work no okay so this
next body type is the the person that
has weight in the hip area and those
types they need to be careful about
excessive estrogen so they want to make
sure that they never consume food with
with just the hormones they want organic
foods they want meats that are grass-fed
hormone free especially dairy yogurt
kefir butter cheese all those things
must not contain hormones because that's
what messed them up they also have to
avoid soy products and that would be
especially in the soy protein isolates
and all the diet shakes read the labels
make sure that you do not consume soy a
lot of the bars that they have right now
are totally loaded with soy and that
acts as estrogen estrogen but the foods
that they should eat are anti estrogenic
foods and that would be the cruciferous
that would be cabbage kale Brussels
sprouts if they had a Cal shake every
day the couple that would be very
beneficial to help balance the estrogen
they can consume a bit more protein and
they can also have a similar eating plan
than the adrenal because the adrenal
over are very similar they produce very
similar hormones okay third shape is the
see if I can pull it up now let's see if
it came up I don't know why that doesn't
show up that's weird
um the ovary type the ovary type let me
see here now they dream the I'm sorry
the thyroid type that is the person
that's gaining weight here we go alright
good we got it perfect okay so the third
type is the person that has gained
weight all over not any one location
that's a thyroid type there's two
primary causes for thyroid one is that
they're not converting the thyroid
hormone through the liver in which case
you need to have them eat foods to
support the liver and that would be not
consuming too much protein maybe having
a lot of vegetables to clean out the
liver and I'm recommending that you have
um when I talk about a more protein I'm
talking about really six to seven ounces
I'm not talking about 8 to 9 to 10
ounces I'm just talking about what you
would consider average okay but if we
want to clean the liver out because if
we look at the last body type that's the
liver type you can see the pot belly
that's a liver type but again the liver
malfunction can cause a thyroid you'd
want to consume foods for the liver so
that would be lower amounts of protein
maybe 2 to 3 ounces of protein with each
meal that's all so this type if it's if
it's like the question is how do you
know if your thyroid problem is coming
from the gallbladder liver or high
estrogen well first of all ask yourself
do you get bloating do you have gall
bladder symptoms do you have liver
problems
have you had your gallbladder removed do
you get burping belching all that you
know those things you should find out
and then if you do then you can go ahead
and start eating correctly for that body
type but when I talk about protein I'm
talking about per meal not per day so if
it's over here on the adrenal type baby
should be consuming about you know 6 to
7 ounces per meal and these liver types
should have at two to three ounces per
meal ok all right now
trying to give you the basics there is
definitely complexities because let's
say you're a little bit of this a little
bit of this a little bit of this what do
you do don't worry about that right now
I will go through a lot of different
cases and we'll just show you what you
should be doing generally speaking
because let's say you're confused and
you don't know if your thyroid problem
is coming from the gallbladder or high
estrogen and let's say it's obvious and
you have a you have good digestion but
you have heavy periods that we know it's
estrogen so now I would have you eat
according to the ovary type because that
is the root cause of the thyroid problem
it's very rare to have a primary thyroid
issue but what's really even interesting
if you have an adrenal case and you get
an autoimmune situation that can also
cause a thyroid issue so you really have
to kind of take the data look at each
part and see what makes sense the other
way to do it is to start with one eating
plan see how you feel see how you do and
then go to the next one and see which
one does better because sometimes you
don't really know unless you try some
people do very well on high protein some
people do not but the thyroid cases
generally need they very well with
cruciferous vegetables but make sure you
have the iodine with seek help that
works really good and they need a small
amount of protein because metabolism is
so slow they can't digest large amounts
of protein the other thing that they
need would be trace minerals trace
minerals help the conversion of proteins
into body tissue like hair nails skin if
you have brittle nails loss of hair you
know skin that's falling off your body
then we know that you might need some
trace minerals to activate the protein
collagen versus just consuming more
protein that which doesn't work so a lot
of people that consume trace minerals
all of a sudden their hair gets stops
falling out they do very well in fact
next Tuesday I'm going to release a
video on that
another question is how much iodine
should you take I always recommend that
you consume it in a food based thing
like seek help you know have like two or
three seek help tablets a day to get
your iodine and that should be enough
you don't necessarily need so much like
four milligrams of iodine whatever like
because iodine works in a complex with
all the minerals and when you consume
straight iodine not a plant-based iodine
it's very difficult for your body to
utilize that it's much better to have a
food base because it breaks down easier
last case is the liver type you can see
the potbelly here this person should not
consume large quantities of protein they
need to do it they would do very well as
a vegetarian because but a real
vegetarian where they're actually eating
vegetables because with that they can
clean out the liver support the liver
and do very well with the gallbladder
and lose a lot of weight because a lot
of that weight in the stomach is fluid
okay all right so that is the body types
now we're going to get into a couple
other things here I'm going to go right
to the next slide let's see if you can
see that oh yeah you can okay good well
guess what
they just found just found out that eggs
are not as bad as they thought they were
I'm talking about the government the new
guidelines governmental guidelines from
the nutritionist finally after 40 years
said that eggs are okay to consume but
they still say that butter is still bad
first of all please please don't get
your health information from the
government if you're not going to get
the correct information it's 40 years -
like eggs like I've been saying for 25
years is that the most perfect food that
you can possibly eat
um in fact let me just go to the next
slide to show you what's in an egg here
we go
I don't know if you can see it but these
are Canadian eggs but if you have eggs
from chickens that are fed organically
free-range they're the best they provide
a lot of vitamins a lot of minerals and
the best part is the yolk the yolk is
where all the real good nutrition is so
if you just eat egg whites you're just
getting a real small portion but in the
yolk they have lecithin to counter
cholesterol so don't worry about that I
do four eggs every single day I've been
doing it forever if you're a female and
you don't weigh that much I weigh 210
pounds maybe you want to do two eggs
okay maybe you don't like eggs I'm just
saying if you like eggs it's a very good
way to get your nutrition so don't worry
about eggs and also butter butter is
actually good it's not a bad thing again
probably another 40 years they'll tell
you it's okay to eat butter there's a
lot of nutrition in butter but I also
always recommend the Kerrygold butter
you can get it from any health food
store okay so a lot of you filled out
your food logs for me too - yeah eggs
are good for all body types by the way
Kim so I'm going to go through some of
the some people who fill out the food
lock so I can analyze their diet so
let's first look at April April for
breakfast she had toast toast and meat
or yogurt with fruit granola or a
smoothie or shake for a snack she
usually does not snack that's fine
grilled chicken wrap with veggies salad
chicken salad no bread with lettuce and
tomato I like that I like that so you
push she probably wraps it with the
lettuce that's a very good idea dinner
maybe nothing depending on how she feels
or vegetable soup beans rice or
vegetables with grilled chicken okay so
the good things are she's having protein
with her breakfast some of it sometimes
that's good I love her lunch that's
really good
I also if she has a good healthy
vegetable soup if she makes it herself
that's really good
again she has vegetables grilled chicken
I'm okay with that
but here's the thing that I want to talk
about you want the breakfast to have no
carbs in it at all
I'm talking about refined carbs and
hidden sugars like toast why because
that is going to nullify any type of
fat-burning effect on your body now Beth
just asked the question I find them very
cyclically eating spring summer fall I
eat a lot of vegetables winter not so
much that's totally fine Beth but here's
the thing make sure you get your
vitamins and minerals from something
believe it or not a lot of the
vegetables that people eat provide most
of the vitamins and minerals the
question is where are you getting them
do you have some type of substitute that
you're going to be able to get your
vitamins from and minerals so make sure
that you have that under control but
toast is going to be a problem it's also
going to slow down fat burning and just
a little bit of toast could knock you on
a fat burning for at least eight hours
unfortunately especially if your
metabolism is low now there are levels
of grains that are better than others
Ezekiel bread is better than white bread
but again if you're trying to burn fat
you might know what a consuming toast
now the yogurt is something else I want
to talk about yogurt make sure that you
do not consume the plain yogurt why I'm
sorry
the vanilla yogurt or the flavored
yogurt because there's a lot of sugar in
that yogurt make sure it's plain and
make sure that it doesn't contain any
sugar added sugar okay another person
says how can I proceed my husband that
eating a little carb will halt fat
burning well have them read my book
watch the videos and try and experiment
try to eat little carbon C if you lose
weight
chances are you won't if you cut the
carb out then you can prove it to
yourself that it works so I always like
to instead of telling someone that this
is true I recommend go ahead demonstrate
it on yourself you put yourself in a
place where you can just do what I'm
recommending and see if it works for you
then then I don't you don't need to
believe me you can just try it I'm just
what I want to do is give you the
mistakes of a lot of people over many
years so you don't have to make the same
mistake over and over and over okay so
now by the way this video is being
recorded so if you're losing connection
it's not it's basically your computer's
not working correctly but this will be
recorded perfectly and it'll be up right
when I get done now the other thing
that's really high in sugar is the
granola granola is massively high in
sugar it's not a good health food
product at all
the other thing is fruit for breakfast I
don't recommend a lot of fruit for
breakfast maybe a little berries but not
a lot why because fruit is turns in the
sugar a lot faster than vegetables so we
don't want to create a blood sugar
problem early under the day if you're
going to have some fruit it's better to
have it in the later part of the day
because this is going to this fruit is
going to affect your sugars and at the
end of the day you're gonna have a
tendency to crave more sweet and be a
little bit more tired so here's a great
thing to test out try this experiment
consume a fruit breakfast granola
breakfast one day and the next day have
a completely protein breakfast and see
how well you do through the day and
you'll be able to prove it to yourself
at the end of the day you have a lot
more energy if you have protein and you
won't have a blood sugar issue and
mentally you won't have brain fog
so the next thing right here she had
grilled chicken okay soup yeah rice and
beans those turn into sugar pretty fast
so you might
avoid those April and the other thing is
that I want to make sure that the
quantity of vegetables are high enough
to provide the nutrition so I don't know
that from what April typed in but I
should have asked her how many cups of
vegetables is she consuming here's some
hidden sugars we got the flavored yogurt
the granola and of course the fiber one
there's just a lot of sugar of these
things um so we labels look at the sugar
grams don't worry about the fat grams or
sodium reps check this out
french vanilla look at low fat this is
what really ticks me off if you go to
the store and you probably try to find
some whole milk you know yogurt I want
the fat in there that's the good part
look at this 28 grams of sugar what
they're doing is they're putting
attention on the fat but not the sugar
the sugar is what's killing them not the
fat so if you're going to have
Stonyfield make sure it is plain and
whole fat okay so that's what I want you
to do on that let's look at Jim Jim has
bacon eggs cheese on a roll so the first
thing I'm going to say is Jim I have no
problem with you doing bacon just buy
the bacon from something like Trader
Joe's where they have no nitrates
hormone-free totally fine it's not a
problem Jim it's not going to hurt you
it's not a bad product some people freak
out about you know pigs but pork but
what happens is that chicken is much
dirtier than pork just so you know so
I'm not against bacon especially if it's
not nitrate free and it's organic and
okay eggs cheese good but this roll has
to go we don't want to do the gruel we
don't want to do the crackers we don't
want to do the bread with the cheese and
ham you'd be much better if you just
took some ham and melted some cheese
over and consume that with a little bit
of salad now the Apple Jim it's not a
problem especially in male bodies the
only time I recommend knock and
sending apples is if you're really
trying to lose weight and you tried
everything an apple could be enough
sugar to slow you down and so in some
people to accelerate weight loss
I'll have them cut out all apples and
I'll switch them to celery and peanut
butter okay so for dinner he has meat
burger sloppy joes tacos and then he has
a cheese cake okay Jim the cheesecake is
going to pretty much you know sit in
your stomach all night the sugar and
you're just going to cause you to gain
weight unfortunately sloppy joes make
sure that you read the label and it
doesn't have all these high fructose
corn syrup and msg and sugar so you want
to avoid that
Carol breakfast two packs of instant
oatmeal oatmeal it's not going to kill
you but it's not going to help you it's
like eating cardboard there's nothing
really in it the other thing you want to
realize is that that carb breakfast at
the end of the day you're going to feel
brain fog tired craving for sweets and
week you probably want to take a nap
right around five six o'clock at night
so you'd want to switch this but if she
just switched the breakfast to a protein
breakfast and let me just show you what
I mean by that see if you can see this
here so if you look right here we have a
kale shake for breakfast and then we
have eggs
one day this person has a little piece
of meat steak omelets eggs totally good
good breakfast looking for lunch some
vegetable with some protein fish perfect
nuts cheese not a problem
another vegetable protein and then look
at Apple hummus cheese nuts snack
this would be a like the ideal scene if
you can do that let me just check the
questions right here yeah so someone
said that they mix blueberries bananas
kale spinach cinnamon eat Wow it's like
ice cream so you're mixing everything I
think you said smart one I don't know
what that is Bradley but smart one turn
beyond to almond milk with blueberries
bananas kale spinach carrots and well
that sounds like a interesting good
thing to do probably like going to shake
the berries in the kale shake
I recommend blueberries and other
berries because that is the lowest
glycemic index versus bananas but you
can do some banana I'm not against that
but again I'm dealing with people that
cannot lose weight no matter what and I
just cut out some of that stuff
especially in the beginning okay now
Carol oatmeal granola bar it's a lot of
sugar I would I'm curious if your yogurt
is flavored it might be again a lot of
sugar to hot dogs
make sure those hot dogs don't have
modified food starch so this is the
ingredients in Oscar Mayer burgers I
mean hot dogs you can see there's a lot
of dextrose that's sugar
hi dries yeast that's msg smoke flavor
not good sodium dices 8/8 sodium we
throw bait made from sugar sodium
nitrate sounds pretty dangerous to me so
make sure you get high quality hotdogs
snacks
marble oranges okay you can do that I
like the idea of having the whole Orange
versus orange juice and then let's say
noodle pea carrot chicken I don't know
what that is but I like the chickens and
the carrots and the peas I don't know if
I like the noodles granola bar again in
1/2 peanut butter sandwich okay so Carol
we need to change some things here
um Joanne 1 and 1/2 cups of coffee with
four level teaspoons of non-dairy
creamer and sucralose so there's
basically let's talk about coffee for a
second I'm not opposed to a small amount
of coffee but I did have one lady who
consumed like 10 to 15 cups today that's
way too much um 1 cup of coffee ok you
can do that I like the idea of having
some organic cream because the non-dairy
creamers have a lot of chemicals in them
so I would be careful of that I like the
idea of you taking sucralose that is a
sugar alcohol so there's two types of
sugars that are acceptable sugar
alcohols and stevia the top of the list
would be xylitol I like that one the
best because it creates the least amount
of digestive issues and it's from birch
bark and it tastes just like sugar
xylitol with an X okay that could be
your sweetener so as I'm looking at your
breakfast where's the food Joanne um
there's no food
so she skips the breakfast at the
evening time she might crave the wrong
thing so she has pack of noodles of
noodles again no nutrition all carbs
dinner sometimes noodles again 2 cups of
spaghetti or two chicken legs die breast
with potato green beans rarely afford
beef but if I do it's usually only one
medium to one Patty I wouldn't have cut
the Box mac and cheese green beans small
piece of beef well then why don't you
buy eggs eggs are not that expensive you
know you can get a whole dozen for $3 so
that's something you might want to try
doing and also vegetables are not that
expensive so if you can't afford organic
then just have regular vegetables that
are not organic because some vegetables
are better than no vegetables okay Karen
so let's talk about Karen um Karen
oatmeal with blueberries again the
oatmeal is something we want to avoid
walnuts are goods good milk I'm not
opposed to that make sure it's one about
free snacks orange juice with seltzer
water there's a lot of sugar in orange
juice unfortunately in fact we just show
you real quick minute mate look at how
much sugars and minivan horseshoes
versus regular orange juice so I rather
orange juice really has no nutritional
value because it's pasteurized all the
vitamin C is destroyed that's why they
add vitamin C back into it but it's
always synthetic there is no benefit
towards juice other than causing a
destruction in your health because it's
so high in sugar okay um it's only good
if you add vodka and you make now just
kidding don't do that that's something
you would do at college okay one slice
of whole grain bread with peanut butter
all right so why don't you put the
peanut butter on the celery two slices
of turkey rolled up with Swiss cheese
okay I like that that is great idea
Karen this is good just mix your cheese
with your protein snack one hard-boiled
eggs few whole a few whole grain
crackers or pretzels all right we need
to cut that out that's not a good snack
sauteed onions garlic
let's see colored drained cabbage oh
that's good oh you stuck in the
cornbread barbecue chicken you were
almost there
Karen but you you you add to the
cornbread so that's that's the thing
that would cut out but you know the
barbecue sauce
there are barbecue sauces that you can
buy with with stevia so just do a search
on stevia Sweden barbecue sauce and
you'll find some really good ones okay
so I see you had some Italian ice cream
just to put the icing on the cake so
that probably will really just kind of
destroy everything you did for that day
Karen but that's because your breakfast
was not
strong enough with protein that's the
only reason to be proudly crave okay
Raquel or Rachel a breakfast protein
powder ah let's see she has hemp rice or
peat I like that that's fine
those are three good protein powders
let's see
warning vitamins okay so everything is
good but where's um okay so you're just
doing protein I think that could be
workable um yeah that could be workable
if you have enough of the protein but if
you're going to do just protein like
that you're probably gonna need at least
25 to 30 grams of protein okay next one
is the snack is the whole oats oat milk
chia seeds plain yogurt okay
frozen berries okay I like everything
except the oats okay let's let's nix
that veggie tacos sauteed sweet potato
sweet potatoes don't have them very
often that you can have them
occasionally and full of kale orange
bell pepper tortilla top with one slice
what's really hot sauce hard-boiled eggs
okay so the cord if we could just mix
the corn you'd be fine on that our
almonds is a great snack quinoa quinoa
is okay it's better than rice in small
quantities all right so now we have
sauteed vegetables totally fun okay so
far so good so she's having a lot of
veggies so she's getting her nutrition
she's just throwing a few too many
things in there that we need to correct
Kimberly so Kimberly has the two eggs on
the toast so that's again you can see a
pattern here with everyone right they
like that toast um blueberry smoothie
with almond okay that's cool that's good
avocado I have a half an avocado with
breakfast every
morning with my eggs nuts are good
two eggs buttered gluten-free toast
again gluten-free but it still is a car
now she has a blueberry smoothie with
almond milk at night that's interesting
not a bad idea okay
Activia low-fat yogurt but I bet you
it's flavored because it's hard to find
plain bacteria there's a lot of sugar on
that by the way bran cereal there's a
lot of sugar in that Apple okay
salad with fresh fat-free dressing no
croutons okay sandwich so just you know
the problem is going to be the bread on
that but I like the idea you're having a
salad that's really good and also lean
meat let's see fiber one chocolate bar
yeah I looked that up fiber one has a
lot of syrup corn syrup rice syrup it's
ten grams of sugar per bar yeah it's
just a little too much sugar it's not a
little too much is actually too much so
that is a situation so I would avoid
that as your snack dinner um chicken
fish small month of red meat with
veggies usually a starch also potatoes
yeah so we got too much starch too many
refined carbs and the Beth is going to
have a hard time losing weight on that
okay Tony
let me just make sure there's any little
questions here how do I feel about hemp
protein yeah hemp protein is totally
fine it's not bad on some people it's
hard to digest so you might want to see
if he goes down well under your system
let's see here I want to see something
here
I want to scan to see if there's any
more questions
okay Tony let's see here 12 ounces of
kale smoothie with almond milk spinach
apple ginger 2 eggs large glass 11 what
I like that see this is good she has the
Apple so Tony is the opposite of vinegar
with lemon water that's really good to
help satisfy the blood Sugar's as well
she has the vegetables this would be a
really good breakfast
okay good a snack apple cheese
rike RISP for those of you that don't
know what that is
i'll show you a picture this is an
acceptable cracker that you could do
it's called rye crisp crackers the thin
ones sometimes they have think caraway
seeds but it's really thin you can put
cheese on it and it's it's totally okay
all right not a problem with that oh you
see if I okay we just go through here
and find my there it's gone again I try
to find that thing see if I can do that
there we go okay so let me just go back
here for a second
Tony all right so right Kris crackers
with all the butter herbal tea totally
fine homemade soup guacamole hummus
omelet totally fine a bottle of water I
just want to make sure that you Tony
you're not drinking water unless you're
thirsty because people are told that
they need a drink drink drink if you
drink too much water um it's going to
flush out electrolytes so only drink
what you're thirsty
oh if you're disagreeing with that then
watch my video on water and just get all
the data okay so now we got dinner we
got fish chicken veggie salad perfect
this is what I recommend and then to
snack at the munchies badly in the
evening now if she's getting the
munchies in the evening then what
happens is that we're going to
and more fat in the breakfast time so
she may need to add a little bit more
like avocado or butter or peanut butter
with celery because she's craving down
here or a little more protein yeah or a
couple more eggs but look at she craves
chocolate bread products like an addict
so if you create chocolate and bread you
may want to consume the B vitamins from
from it's called nutritional yeast and
that should curb your cravings for bread
okay chocolate that could be an adrenal
issue see I try to avoid and eat more
veggies but I find it hard to yeah I
would actually go with more fat of your
foods than veggies like cheese like
peanut butter with celery let's see okay
she likes chocolate
alright let's take a look at something
here let's take a look at this right
here
lilies lilies chocolate is flavored with
stevia this would be a good chocolate to
consume because if you really need
chocolate at least it has zero sugars
okay so someone Jim asked could your
kale shake or almond milk be a good
breakfast yes but it might not be enough
protein I do have another Cal shade
coming down the pike I'm going to take
about two months to get it though it's
going to have a high amount of protein
because I do some people are trying to
get more protein so I'm going to add
more protein but you'd have to add a
couple eggs to that says which do you
prefer egg protein powder or pea protein
powder personally I would do the egg
protein powder in the shake absolutely
nutritional yeast is so powerful in
flavor can it go in soup can it be
heated good question
um yes it can be heated but not overly
heated but yes you I like to put it in
you can put it in peanut butter you can
put it in plain yogurt you can put it in
soup
absolutely okay let's see here
all right Lina breakfast let's see what
she consumes I guess that's not 80
ounces of juice that must be 8 ounce
glass juice vegetables and fruit wait a
half-hour and a cup of coffee no sugar
she has she has the pumpernickel bagel
or toast bread with grass-fed butter so
the question is what do you put your
butter on I am going to release very
soon a recipe for English muffins that
you can make that tastes just like
English muffins but they're not made
from any wheat at all or grains so I
will settle it out so that way you can
put your butter on it it's from one of
my patients who had this recipe I loved
it it was amazing so I will make it and
then share that of a video ok all right
so we got let's see occasion weekend's
omelet all right sandwich that bread
needs to go i some day this skip
breakfast just had my juice of coffee
yeah well at night you're gonna crave ok
she also has for lunch vegetables good
she has that without so let's see
mayonnaise mayonnaise is totally fine
don't worry about that um let's see
oh here we go one teaspoon of agave
nectar agave nectar is very similar to
honey it still turns into sugar fat I
mean almost as close as is honey and so
it's not a low glycemic sweetener I
don't recommend it especially if you're
trying to lose weight ok so his barbecue
chicken and she had the fries or rice ok
that is an issue whole grain it's going
to stop weight loss potatoes so we're
gonna have to just avoid all the
starches let's see
they're meat eaters that's fine but just
don't add all the starches and
Barb's okay alright here we go carry
gold butter is the best butter because
it's grass-fed butter and carry gold
also makes the best cheese I love this
cheese it's really good and it's
grass-fed so it has vitamin k2 so let's
say Jacqueline says all this works no
doubt about it but I always fail to
maintain the changes to my diet and
revert back to old ways and gain the way
back how do I stop this well I just
created a video on that it should come
out tomorrow on self-discipline because
it's something that people slide into
because the thing with your body stantly
create a healthy body and it's something
that takes work just like a relationship
you have to constantly put it there so
you might slide into old habits but I
think what you should do is find these
little substitute things that you really
like recipes that are like healthy junk
food you can download on my website and
start incorporating healthier ways to
make the junk food and make sure it's
healthy and that way you're not
necessarily depriving yourself ok Diane
says I wake up very hungry um so so let
me just see what she's doing here if
you're waking up hungry then we need to
make sure that you we add more protein
or some fat but she wants salty pretzels
a chocolate and a glass of good wine so
here's the thing if you have low blood
sugars you really need to work on fixing
of that I have a lot of videos on how to
do with blood sugar issues and what you
should eat so to the point where your
blood sugars are better about or better
because I will tell you that if your
sugars are low if you have low blood
sugars you will crave because of that
so as you do this you're going to have
to start realizing that Ukrainians won't
go away until your blood Sugar's are
well established I used to have
hypoglycemic so bad but I tell you that
the eating plan that I'm showing you
right here will correct it over time all
right
is Kerrygold
organic as far as I know it is but it's
grass-fed so most hundred percent
positive it is because I know they don't
put pesticides in it um I best as I find
if I eat in the morning when I'm not
hungry I'm starving all day oh you get
up at 5:00 okay
well maybe you should just eat at 8:00
or 9:00 so just yeah because the whole
circadian rhythm doesn't kick in because
you're waking up extra early so
that'sthat's fine you can eat at 9:00 or
10:00 not a problem and that works for
you totally fun yeah I like that
okay Cheryl two eggs so here we go with
the toast again
sourdough spelt steel-cut oatmeal honey
it's just going to be too much carbs
Cheryl okay Greek yogurt blueberries
avocado I like this I like this snack
but the apple juice has to go sorry
um lean protein good Apple or roll nuts
with cheese okay lean protein everything
else is good of course
ice cream needs to go there are types of
ice cream that are zero carbs you can
try to find some I think I have that
and my little booklet on my website you
can download it here's a little chart
that will give you some data on fat
burning on one of my links on my website
fat burning foods after ebooks you can
download this little sheet some of you
have it already but it's a good little
summary of what we talked about with
that burning of so it's dr. Berg comm
ebooks for slash fat burning foods for
- burning - foods okay you could
download that Albert breakfast he gets
up too late around ten eleven maybe bowl
of cereal you sound like me when I was
18 Albert snack whatever food is
available okay lunch whatever's
available chili luxe beans in a can
maybe frozen pizza of our camp food so
Albert either you're new to my website
and you have not watched any of the
videos that I had over the last 15 years
or you know or maybe that's the reason
or you're not complying with what I'm
recommending but Albert I recommend get
on my list start watching the video
start getting educated on what you need
to do but you definitely need some
serious changes with your eating plan
but I create you being honest Thank You
Evelyn okay we have one egg bacon half
tomato totally fine not a problem with
this breakfast make sure you put no
sweeteners in the coffee unless it's a
little I think maybe this is some rye
cracker I'm not sure what that that is
with cumin tomato salad with lettuce
okay so this this is good this is good I
think this is a right cracker thing
these are salt tannaz are like raisins
they do have a bit too much sugar so you
might not want to add that I like the
roll nuts though I like to stay
convertibles and fresh fruit so I think
Evelyn you're real close and again
you're having vegetables all over the
place so that's good here's that little
sheet that I listed and uh I'm going to
every month that I do these webinars I
always get people a kind of little
little bonus for being on the website a
lot of you are taking the wheatgrass
juice powder um
if you go to amazon.com and you enter
the code you you can take $10 off this
product it's basically uh it's not
wheatgrass juice powder its wheatgrass
I'm sorry it's not wheatgrass powder its
wheatgrass juice powder one teaspoon is
equivalent to fourteen of shots of
wheatgrass juice powder if their days
that I don't have enough enough
vegetables I will do the wheatgrass
juice powder if I'm working out and
training intensely I'll do two teaspoons
of the wheatgrass root powder there's a
it's a bit better than my multivitamin
mineral super nutrient and the trace
minerals because it's grown on soils
that are very fertile with with the
trace minerals so this is something that
to really spike like it's kind of like
the best multivitamin mineral that you
give because there's a trace minerals
it's super concentrated and it doesn't
taste too bad but when you mix in water
it's a little clumpy because I didn't
want so it's it it's the real high
quality stuff so again this is you can
have to go to Amazon you click on this
but all I ask if you get this all I'm
going to ask you is to write an unbiased
review on this product because I would
really appreciate that okay so if you
wanted to test it out but for those that
are already getting this I'm giving you
a little discount with that each month
I'll do something like this so it's $10
off now I'm going to answer some
questions
okay so Linda's said she's on auto-ship
for wheatgrass yes so what we'll do
Linda is call the office and have them
if you're already in auto-ship will
allow you to take an additional $10 off
because I don't think you're getting the
auto-ship is not on Amazon so call the
office and I will let them do that just
tell them I said it's okay okay you also
mentioned you do the kale shake and
refrigerate it overnight that is really
good to do
because though if you keep a kale shake
in your refrigerator overnight the
enzymes help break down the product more
so it's easier to digest in the morning
what I'm doing now is I'm taking the
kale already chopped up I buy it chopped
up and then I add I add I'm sorry I put
in the freezer so then I take that
frozen kale and blend it with fruit it
really turns out really good okay
Patricia it's she says it sounds like
you are recommending a no carb diet what
if I go to the gym to lift weights and
play tennis should I have some extra
carbs so Patricia you're going to get
your carbs from all those vegetables but
let's pretend that you're not interested
in losing weight that you can have more
fruit carbs but what we're trying to
avoid is the carbs that turn on the
sugar quickly the refined grains the
breads pastas cereal crackers there's
this thought out there that you need the
sugar to get energy but you really don't
because your body will turn that even
protein into into the sugar that you
need because your body is always storing
a certain amount of sugar so it is a
myth that you need excess sugar for
energy in fact the excess sugar will
cause you to become more tired so in
other words if you consume the excess
sugar it will take away from your energy
that it will give you energy okay so let
me see if I have any other questions
here
what type
diet works good for scleroderma and all
esophageal stomach intestinal issues
again you would need to stick with the
eating plan with the adrenal because
that's an autoimmune thing but I will
say intestinal issues do really well on
cabbage cabbage has certain product of a
certain chemical in her that is really
good for the digestive tract let's see
here Kimberly when a lot of protein in
my kidneys hurt well then then we know
that you probably liver case and I would
consume small months protein three
ounces that's a situation you don't want
to consume if you're eating a food and
you have a reaction to it and we can
narrow down what kind of body type you
are based on that so that's actually
good data also says I don't I don't eat
a full meal I feel pain around my liver
and gallbladder well I would love Kim
for you to send me what you eat so I can
dissect that and see why that is you may
need a more of something like some gall
bladder formula to help loosen up the
bile ducts to get more vile John says
his frozen cap on the supermarket okay
to use in this shake instead of fresh
yeah because that is fresh it's just
frozen not a problem
okay says I love the wheatgrass my
husband and I have been using it for
about one year it gives me lots of
energy yeah the wheatgrass is the is the
most powerful thing that I have because
it's so super concentrated and you're
getting a tremendous amount attrition
because it's it's it's a juice powder
grown on ancient seabeds so it has all
the trace minerals but I like that the
best I I basically take that as my multi
everything especially when I'm working
out and has a lot of chlorophyll to and
has no gluten Emily says well I've
eventually stopped having intense
cravings around the monthly cycle if I
start eating no Emily what we need to do
is we need to fix your menstrual cycle
which is then
your hormones off cause you to crave so
what I'm going to recommend is you take
the ovary support formula to handle the
cycle and if you're in the area I've
stopped my office let me check you if
you're not I would take the ovary
formula because it's not really a food
issue it's a menstrual cycle issue that
we need to solve by fixing the ovarian
output of estrogen sarah says I
developed a yeast yeast infection but we
could go let there after starting
nutritional yeast I highly doubt that
the yeast infection that you have is
coming from your nutritional yeast
because it's it's actually not something
that is going to give you yeast you have
a balance of good yeast and unfriendly
yeast a good use will only provide the
good use it will not add the bad yeast
in there the yeast infections usually
come from something that's destroying
the natural good yeast inside your
system so I have a hard time believing
it came from that uh Kimberly says where
do I send my data information I would
call my office on the website in and get
roxanna's email she can be she's my
communicator and I get all the emails to
her okay supplements for a diabetic
besides nutritional yeast
I should probably create a video on that
but definitely number one my adrenal day
formula
an old Patriot trophy get that for my
office that's good for a pankratov in PG
write that down and I would do those two
things that would help your blood
Sugar's and support healthy sugars hair
thinning well you have to watch the next
video that I have a next Tuesday I'll
release that one own hair I'm going to
talk about how to get your hair really
solid in fact uh I use it on my wife and
it worked very well in she's 52 and she
started losing hair I gave her this egg
boom hair came right back okay I have a
friend who had a pinched nerve at l5 now
getting a foot drop I recommend her to
take on ik minimalist Bao salts any
recommendation well foot drop usually is
coming from some type of pinched nerve
at l5 if there's no injury involved it
could be virus related and that's why
the trace minerals help because trace
minerals put viruses back in remission
okay Jim says any recommendations for
food to eat when you're on the road
travel lot that's cheese celery fruit
apples okay John if I could see
wheatgrass juice powder with the BT need
for organic cruciferous food don't like
to eat a lot of vegetables well the it's
the best way to get your nutrition from
the wheatgrass other than eating the
vegetables so yes that would be an
alternative because think about it
one teaspoon is equal to four 14 shots
of wheatgrass juice 14 shots of
wheatgrass juice that is like equivalent
to a huge tray of wheatgrass 20 by 10
inches 20 inches by 10 inches in one
teaspoon so if you had one of those you
did getting every single nutrient you
would need including all the fat almost
all the fat soluble vitamins in one
teaspoon and you put that in water and
slug it down and you'll start feeling a
lot more energy let's see
Beatrice says of 16 a probably a mix
between adrenal and estrogen I do not
like dairy except full fat cheese's
would you Rebecca how hood
say how would you recommend getting
enough calcium well I would get it from
you don't like well get the full fatty
cheese's I would eat the cheese that
cheese feta cheese I would also get
something called kefir playing keeper
but also if you want to get your calcium
that realize that you're going to need
vitamin D and vitamin k2 I have some
videos on that so instead of trying to
add more calcium get the vitamins that
transport calcium in the bones will be
much much better especially if you're 60
ok so Bradley a teaspoon of turmeric and
a half glass of water orange juice at
night also do now that's tumeric is
totally fine it's a really good product
I like that not a problem
Debbie says is it necessary worry about
calories no it's not it's the type of
food that you need not the calories ok
so I would recommend basically sticking
with what I talked about here and you'll
come out ahead but don't worry about the
calories so it's been an hour and I want
to thank everyone for coming out of the
cemetery like I will continue to do
these monthly just to share some good
information and I'll leave this up for a
couple minutes
uh if you want to test out the
wheatgrass juice you can order that you
have to go to amazon.com and just type
under wheatgrass juice dr. Berg and
it'll pop right out ok have a wonderful
evening
and I will talk to you very soon all
right thank thanks for your interest
everyone
you